[Music]
her
heart free snowboarding tickets probably
like a personalized P of agility well we
did get engaged so I guess an engagement
ring was my best present while I was
here yeah
and for you you got me some nice After
Shave which is lovely maybe
flowers um Sephora gift Sephora a
Sephora gift card um a trip to New York
City I was going to say a trip as well I
mean it can be anywhere but a trip an
experience kind of yeah a
trip that yeah so anything like handmade
I feel like something small like thought
about it for sure yeah something which
is uh which is
customized uh for people who who are
knowing me they know that I like
photography so something which is linked
with photography or Sports probably a
good meal i' say at a nice
restaurant yeah like maybe something a
little bit more person I don't know if
she she knows like what's what you're
into like I would say kitchen wear for
me the diamonds Jewels rubies
um clothes in need any any desire
clothing luckily we've been fortunate
enough we don't need a whole lot so uh
it's just being together as a family is
great for
us